The notion of axiomatic concepts is the classical view in cognitive systems.
Here's an alternative view. This is called Prototypical concepts.
Prototypical concept is a base concepts defined by some typical
properties that can sometimes be overridden. So, an example is a chair. You and
I have a notion of a prototypical chair. Our notion of a prototypical chair may
have, for example, there is a back, there is four legs and so
on. So, here might be your and my notion of a prototypical chair. It has a back,
it has a seat, it has four legs and so on. Now I can represent this notion of
the prototypical chair in the language of frames. This is something we have come
across earlier in the class. A frame has slots and fillers, as you may recall,
and we use frames to represent stereotypes. Here we're talking about prototypes,
so very closely related. So concept is the a content you can represent.
Frame is the form in which we can represent it. So a notion for
the prototypical chair might be, it has four legs, it, the material is metal,
it has a back, it does not have arms, and it's not cushioned.
Note that these are the typical properties of a chair. Of course, some chairs
need not necessarily satisfy all of these properties. That is why there are no,
no necessary and sufficient conditions here. For example, we may come across
a chair. Which is made of wood. While you would still consider it a chair,
even if you're not strictly satisfied with this particular definition.
Thus, these properties can be overridden in case of specific instances.
But we'll still have the basic notion of a prototypical chair so
that we can in fact communicate with each other about what a chair is.
Despite the fact that we can override these properties we do still have
a notion of prototypical chair. So the relationships between concepts and
frames actually is quite close. Recall that when we were talking about frames,
we were also talking about inheritance and default. The notion of default in
frames is closely connected to the notion of typical properties and concepts. So
chair has this prototypical notion with some of these typical properties, and
we can think of this as having a default values. By default, we assume
the number of legs is four, the material is metal and so on. Here is a stool and
this stool is a kind of chair which means that it inherits all the values and
all the slots that are there in the chair directly except for
those that happen to be different from the one in the chair. So then an example
here it over writes a notion that the chair necessarily has to have a back.
In the case of a stool, the stool does not have a back.